emmanuel macron serait à 23% emmanuel
macron bouche très peu il est toujours
entre 23 et 25 % c'est assez incroyable
c'est vrai que c'est le seul qui reste
assez stable fort et nancy nikki expert
en communication et surtout un ami et un
gars que j'aime alors mon florian
c'est fou saint florent mais la position
de macron non puisque le président de la
république ils bénéficient et c'est un
atout incontestable dont peut d'ailleurs
deux présidents de la république ont pu
bénéficier jusque là il bénéficie d'un
socle qui ne bouge pas et dont bernard
montiel quoi qu'ils disent déjà bernard
montiel en fait c'est le socle il ya
bernard montiel et après il ya tout le
monde mais c'est vrai que fidèle parmi
les mois je suis assez étonné voilà par
les intentions de vote des manuels mâcon
qui ne bouge pratiquement pas c'est le
seul en fait dès qu'il est candidat
aujourd'hui qui a vraiment son socle
avant il y avait la même chose pour
marine le pen c'est toujours marine le
pen à la manier dans le socle est là on
va en parler justement ce soir eric
zemmour est il en train d'exploser
l'extrême droite est d'ailleurs aussi la
droite ou d'en parler avec deux témoins
aussi qu'ils sont la marine le pen à 16%
ça fait très très très longtemps qu'on
avait pas vu marine le pen aussi basse
dont les sondages si c'est pratiquement
historique et c'est vrai ce qui est
dingue c'est que si on additionne marine
le pen eric zemmour on a un peu les
anciens score de marine le pen des
intentions de vote au premier tour 28
c'est vrai qu'on arrive 28-28 en juin
quand il avait ensuite à la peur du tout
ce point et pourrait monter à 13 donc il
ya quand même un chou pas très bons en
maths mais bon il ya quand même
c'est fou oui mais ce qu'on mesure lâché
zemmour c'est d'abord sa popularité pour
l'intense des mourides à un public de
fidèles il n'y a pas une conversion en
militant par ailleurs l'histoire nous
apprend que c'est trop tôt aujourd'hui
pour juger sinon jean pierre chevènement
à cette époque il a fini à 5 % la
présidentielle françois fillon il aurait
été élu quant à françois hollande
n'aurait pas été mal ça veut dire c'est
un peu tôt là je vais dire la vérité moi
je pense que c'est yann dit c'est quand
même il ya quand même eu ni leur mener
la vie et d'ailleurs c'est en général ce
qui est important dans huit heures je
vais te dire florian pourquoi c'est
important je veux dire aux
téléspectateurs pourquoi c'est important
c'est très simple c'est qu'aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui se passe en politique en
politique c'est commenter
et quand vous avez le vent en poupe vous
avez tout le monde derrière nous quand
les audiences ont moins bonne on avait
tout le monde commence à dire ah ouais
il est fini il faut pas aller chez lui
en politique c'est pareil donc qu'est ce
qui se passe autour d'eric zemmour c'est
pour ça que c'est important aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui vont
se dire on va soutenir eric zemmour il
le voit ou dans les sondages et surtout
ce qui va se passer c'est que marine le
pen je pense qu'il ya de plus en plus de
soutien de marine le pen qui vont se
dire elle n'a aucune chance de gagner
donc forcément il faut la laisser tomber
c'est pour ça que c'est chez claude
important les sondages aujourd'hui
pourquoi ils sont importants c'est sûr
que le président d'aujourd'hui est le
premier de red sonja aujourd'hui ne sera
peut-être pas le président en mai mais
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est que le
en fait l'échiquier politique est en
train de se former et aujourd'hui il ya
la droite on connaît pas encore le
candidat donc quand est-ce que c'est
vrai que dernier bertrand est ce que
savait de valérie pécresse est ce que la
droite va se dire aussi un moment
écoutez peut-être ce sera yves bertrand
ni valérie pécresse mais peut-être
faisons une droite républicaine avec
eric zemmour est peut-être réunissions
toutes les droites s'est pas
complètement impossible pour avoir une
chance d'aller au bout donc voilà donc
c'est ça qui se passe aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui on le voit marine le pen
d'ailleurs on aura jordan bardella
demain avec nous marine le pen
aujourd'hui on voit ya de plus en plus
de gens c'est ce qui ressort aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que disent tous les
spécialistes et décline une interview
d'un spécialiste politique ou d'un
responsable politique la première chose
qui lie c'est marine le pen n'a plus
aucune chance de gagner donc forcément
les électeurs de marine le pen ils
disent aujourd'hui nous on a déjà voté
pour elle en 2017 elle a perdu on veut
quelqu'un c'est puisse aller au bout
donc c'est ça le truc et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que c'est
important qu'il y ait ce un bon flow je
sais que les chiffres d'aujourd'hui
seront pas ici de demain mais
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est vous et
d'avoir besoin d'alliés et là avec la
dynamique qu'il a de plus en plus de
gens moi j'attends qu'ils disaient bat
eric zemmour pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
il a par ailleurs un atout zemmour que
beaucoup d'autres n'ont pas c'est qu'il
est autant capable de parler aux
électeurs de jean marie le pen qui ont
fait 2 2 de marine le pen pardon qui
sont très bourgeois et qui aime son
propos patiné de culture d'histoire et
cetera que à l'ouvrier qui s'est
toujours engagé en politique et la
capacité de faire l'union entre ces deux
électorats c'est évidemment une force
que beaucoup n'ont pas aujourd'hui
par ailleurs il arrive à intéresser les
français à la chose politique à un
moment où les français nous disent que
la campagne présidentielle ne les
intéresse pas et ça fait d'eric zemmour
un danger pour la classe politique
actuelle c'est pour ça qu'on a vu
françois hollande nicolas sarkozy se
monte au créneau et tenter à l'image
aussi d'ailleurs de jean françois copé
et d'autres qui sévit à l'écart de la
chose politique de tenter de remettre
l'église au vide alors justement est-ce
qu'on va la vie de nicolas sarkozy qui
donne son avis sur eric zemmour il a été
extrêmement durs un nicolas sarkozy il a
eu des mots durs par rapport à anvers
eric zemmour regardez quand on touche
aux parents de l'école de toulouse sage
accepte pas qui en inhumer leurs
inscrits en israël ce que j'étais
président de la république
je les ai vus jamais je les oublierai
jamais j'oublierai le visage de cette
femme ait perdu ses enfants son frère
pour moi
on doit pas aller toucher parce qu'ils
sont intouchables voilà ici vols
allaient se faire enterrer en israël on
les laisse tranquilles c'est respectable
alors qu'eric zemmour à nicolas sarkozy
on aimerait la voir l'autre extrait
intérêts sur eric zemmour quand il a dit
vraiment pour lui que c'était le degré
zéro de la politique nicolas sarkozy
mais bon la production a pris le mauvais
extraits vous prenez bien qu'ils ne
peuvent pas que sur tous les coûts non
plus voilà si vous l'avez dites le moi
oui mais si pour un sarkozy qui est
clair comme ça il y en a d'autres qui
sont un peu plus empêtré à droite
notamment christian jacob quand même qui
voilà qui tient devant vous l'a demandé
de qualifier zemmour et il a refusé de
qualifier on me dise qu'il est d'extrême
droite est ce qu'il est raciste il a dit
il et zemmour donc on voit que la droite
elle est un petit peu embêté parce
qu'elle veut pas non plus le montrer du
doigt zemmour parce qu'elle se dit
j'aimerais bien récupérer les électeurs
de zemmour en même temps il ya quand
même des digues qu'il faut vaut qu'il
faut mettre montée en disant c'est pas
nous c'est pas les mêmes valeurs ils
sont trés emmerder alors bon pas un truc
très amusant d'ailleurs zemmour il fait
du marketing électoral l envers et au
fond il a une offre politique qui est
basée sur ce qui peut rattraper contre
l'autre donc il balance un truc contre
les femmes il balance un truc contre les
homos et lobbys lgbt un truc contre les
musulmans et à chaque fois il espère
récupérer un électorat chez qui ce
propos fait qu est ce cet amusant parce
que c'est une segmentation électoral que
l'on avait vu déployés notamment par
emmanuel macron mais exactement à
l'envers
autres ensuite alors quand on écoute
eric zemmour on comprend que sa
candidature fait de moins en moins de
doute déjà l'association des amis d'eric
zemmour a trouvé ce qg de 400 mètres
carrés dans un immeuble du viiie
arrondissement proche du palais l'elysée
donc eric zemmour aurait un qg donc si
on a un qg c'est pas pour recevoir voilà
des potes candidats on s'est tu peux pas
boire eric zemmour est candidat et le
csa quelles que soient les défauts de
l'anticipation de sa décision il avait
bien besoin de bien sorti même qu'il
serait candidat eric zemmour on pas
mentir aux gens qui n'ont rien il va
être candidat et d'ailleurs il fait un
truc amusant c'est qu'il a copié collé
la campagne de jean-marie le pen en 2002
il en prend les thématiques il en prend
les accents il en reprend les phrases
son modèle c'est manifestement celle ci
ça pose une question encore les recettes
il ne voulait pas tellement être
président de la république et j'en
termine là il ya un chiffre qui est très
fort que son équipe devrait prendre en
compte parce que c'est un chiffre qui va
être important s'il veut vraiment être
présent de la république c'est qu'il est
la personnalité politique la plus
rejetée par les français il y a 6
français sur 10 qui vous disent on ne
veut pas d'eric zemmour enfin on a on
accole pas eric zemmour quelque chose de
positif et ça c'est évidemment une
difficulté parce que malgré les
militants qui peuvent se constituer
derrière vous sur le propos politique
que vous tenez il ya aussi cette france
capable de se mobiliser contre vous et
on sait par exemple que le tout sauf
sarkozy ça a fait mal à nicolas sarkozy
puisque les lecteurs a mobilisé contre
lui avait fini par être plus fort que
ses militants qu'il soutenait alors
regardez là dit il était dans le grand
rendez vous sur ces news europe 1 avec
sonia mabrouk et franchement là ça fait
plus aucun doute un regarde
s'il n'y avait pas est ce que vous
sentez que plusieurs numéros une
trahison c'est à dire que vous avez
porter une parole vous avez incarné ça
vous avez des c'est le désir monte et au
dernier moment vous nous finalement
jours de vie commentateurs c'est une
vraie question est la ré pas
la réponse je la donnerai bientôt vous
inquiétez pas mais la réponse à la
réponse à la question c'est
qu'effectivement de noble et éthique
mais non mais je fais pas le politique
jusqu'à présent je vous ai pas vraiment
fait le politique n'a pas la langue de
bois non je vous dis simplement je
choisirai mon moment c'est pas de la
langue de bois je dis voilà est-ce que
vous pouvez ne pas y aller ou non mais
c'est une vraie ce que johan bonnaud pas
y aller j'ai un oui je peux toujours ne
pas y aller les meilleurs tous ceux à
qui j'ai effectivement je descend jamais
si je n'y allais pas je ne décevrai ayes
beaucoup de gens ça c'est sûr